welcome welcome welcome welcome welcome
to the heavy spoilers show I'm your host
Paul and variant assemble as we're
breaking down episode 6 of Loki the
season has now come to a close but that
doesn't mean that there isn't a lot to
talk about and our glorious purpose for
this video is to go over the Easter eggs
things you missed devil in the details
and ending to give our full thoughts on
the first season now it's been a long
week waiting to see who's inside the
castle at the end of time and our last
episode ended with Loki until we heading
out to reveal who was behind the curtain
joined by classic Loki they managed to
enchant Eliot and open up the
trans-dimensional being to step into
Bowser's Castle Mobius decided that he
was gonna go and burn the entire TVA to
the ground and I forgot to mention last
week that this was actually a call back
to the first episode in which Loki said
he was gonna do the same thing that
should have you pretty much caught up
and from here on out it's full spoilers
ahead so I suggest to make sure you're
pruned if you don't want to have this
ruined please click the Thumbs Up Button
if you and enjoy the video and thank you
so much for your support over the last
six weeks I love E3000 and I hope you've
enjoyed it as much as I have now let's
get into Loki episode 6. now we pick up
with the Marvel Studios logo and over
the top of some distinctive sound
effects from the MCU this includes Tony
Stark's Repulsor blast as well as
several quotes from our characters over
the years there's several in there such
as how about it adds off and I can do
this all day now these are really
important as these Timeless moments in
the MCU have of course made up the
universe and we cut to space to travel
through hours there's a ship here that
flies by but I couldn't quite make out
what it was however if you can then let
me know below maybe it's the missing
astronauts from One Division who are
actually the Fantastic Four or maybe I
have the powers of Reed Richards because
that's a big reach more like reach
Richards eh you're having that now the
episode itself is called for all time
always which is of course a moniker of
the TVA over the logo there's also the
song it's been a long long time by Harry
James in Helen Forrest this was played
at the end of Avengers end game and the
word play of the title of course plays
into time too now in the episode where
introduced to Jonathan magers playing he
who remains King Kang ain't got [ __ ] on
me because we said all the way back in
our episode one video that it would be
he who was behind it however we might
have also said 7 000 other fan theories
since then but but just ignore them and
focus on the one we got right now it
takes forever to say he who remains and
I'm probably going to be mentioning this
guy a lot in the video so to keep things
simple I am just going to be saying Kang
even though this guy is pretty much one
of his many variants now there were
several Clues towards this such as the
central timekeeper bearing a big
resemblance to him the king building
Elias and even the colors when the polar
opened were blue purple and green which
are of course Kang's colors now from the
universe we travel into the Multiverse
and get an almost Wormhole effect which
resembles the bifrost slightly this is
of course used to travel from one place
nice and space and time to another and
now we are seeing how it's expanded into
a much greater Universe now it's also
another 2001 A Space Odyssey in which a
character reached the monolith and then
traveled through this weird dimensional
portal in order to learn a higher
knowledge much like how the characters
and audience do in this episode upon
going inside they're greeted by Miss
minutes and she says this is the Citadel
which might be another Starlight Citadel
from the comics which is a location that
exists in the outer World however it may
also be a call back to Thor 245 which
dealt with the temple at the end of time
but here the name has been changed up
now the showrunner said that this is
carved out of Black Stone because there
were no other elements that existed this
far into the future and the cracks in
the building very much foreshadow the
cracks in the Multiverse Kang has been
monitoring them and going under the name
he who remains which is the pseudonym
that the last surviving TBA agent went
under similar to what we see he created
the timekeepers but rather than being a
malevolent Force he was actually a a
good person and even thought to be a
very old Mobius and Mobius he who
remains was another one of our theories
so I'm glad that they kind of combined
it into this Kang reveal as the villain
has had several monikers over the years
too Miss minutes offers them a Faustian
deal here in which they'll be able to
rule over an entire timeline Loki will
be able to kill Thanos and due to Kang's
control over time he can manipulate the
event so that he can have whatever his
heart desires so we can have the same
thing her dreams coming true and they'll
share a timeline together however they
turn down the deal and decide to write
their own destiny now recently Sofia
dimartino talked about this element in
an interview and she said that the
series as a whole is sort of asking
whether we have free will and can escape
our destiny we've not only seen this in
the TVA who wanted to control what
happens in the sacred timeline but also
the characters themselves Loki is of
course a villain that might be a good
guy but there's also the idea that he'll
give in to as much darker nature and
that he doesn't really have a choice
because because he is who he is this
idea comes with the Betrayal at the end
and we see that people are very much
Bound by who they are now cut back to
ravona rentslayer being greeted by Miss
minute who doesn't view time in a linear
fashion and instead he's able to jump
back and forth between it she's brought
some info for Ren Slayer who still looks
longingly over the ring stains that
Mobius Left Behind showing she is
grappling with what she's done so far
back with Loki and Sylvie the pair step
further into the lair and we see the
Three Time Keeper statues as well as a
destroyed one on the floor this very
much juxtaposes the end of the episode
in which we see a statue of a Kang
variant and potentially he who remains
destroyed this because he didn't want to
be reminded of the face that would
conquer everything Kang is eating an
apple something that is used in the
biblical sense to symbolize knowledge it
was of course the fruit that also
tempted Adam and Eve and Kang is very
much a devil at points tempting them
with potential happiness and knowledge
Beyond what's happened before now I'm
not doing any devil Mephisto jokes as I
swear however he does refer to himself
as the devil and Shout Out Simon a
bearman on Twitter for pointing out that
Loki and Selby very much represent Adam
and Eve e was created from Adam much in
the same way that Sylvie was created
from Loki and again it's like poetry
they Rhyme now they could remain in this
paradise ruling over everything will be
cast out into the unknown to fend for
themselves and that's very much the
choice they're given I love how he uses
the time twister as a weapon to walk
around and it's one of the creepiest
Marvel villain intros that we've ever
had instead of the time twister though
yeah maybe you should have just used
pheromones and they wouldn't have been
able to get close to you you're having
that cornea the dislike buttons there go
on press it press it it's your destiny
now this episode and just the series in
general pulls heavily from the book
agent of Asgard I know some of you hate
when I go up into the comics behind the
show as you'd rather I focused on the
episode but time codes will be linked
below if you want to skip ahead however
I think it's worth going over as we can
see see where it lines up with the show
and how certain elements were pulled
across whilst others were changed now
that book followed a Loki who had been
given a second chance after his death
due to suffering years of defeat at the
hands of the Avengers and Thor Loki
decided to go on A New Path and become
an agent of Asgard that would right the
wrongs of the past firstly he set out to
get the sort of sigured AKA Graham which
may have been given an odd to in the
show due to its ability to set on fire
he also encountered several versions of
himself namely King Loki which was a
possible timeline in which he was the
true god of Mischief the evil one
now he went through a lot of Trials and
tests and in the end it was revealed
that Loki was a puppet used to improve
others the old mother divulged that she
was simply fooling him as she didn't
expect him to be anything more than a
villain that was used to propel others
to Greatness now the timeline kind of
gets confusing here and the original
Loki that learned this ended up becoming
an even worse villain he thought that if
they wanted a big bad that he would play
that role to Perfection and give them
one of the most fearsome foes they'd
ever set Their Eyes Upon he became old
and twisted and ended up traveling back
in time to manipulate his younger self
into facing more challenging trials so
that they would improve him now when the
whole plot with the all mother was
revealed for the second time to the
version that had been manipulated by
Loki he ended up turning against his
Destiny Loki embraced himself and casts
out the king version so that he could go
on to become something different that
hadn't been seen before and in many ways
the Loki version did Propel himself to
Greatness now other allusions to that
book beyond the personal growth is that
the final issue you did take place in
what could be classified as the void for
asgardia not as God it's called asgardia
but that's another story now what we see
in this episode does carry a similar
notion as it exists at the End of Time
much in the same way that that room
existed outside of time and space now
here we see this idea not only reflected
in Loki but also in Kang who we discover
used himself and his variants to improve
on one another however it ended up with
some wishing to rule over the others and
just all-out war in the Multiverse now
cut back to the TVA and we see Mobius
confronting rensslayer in her office the
latter is still indoctrinated even after
learning the truth and we discover the
origin of the pen from the Franklin D
Roosevelt High School B15 has tracked
things back to 2018 and we discover that
Ren Slayer was a teacher there I think
that it was Eric Boss that called this
out so shout out to him for getting it
way early and potentially here learning
this ended up creating her Nexus event
Wren Slayer clearly doesn't want to
break free of Kang's Rule and this has
been that in several of her appearances
namely down to the timekeeper which
looks extremely like him looming over
her constantly back in Kang's office he
divulges that he already knows the
outcome of every scenario as he has his
script it's very similar to the Doctor
Who episode blink which involved people
discovering secret messages on DVDs from
the Doctor Who had recorded them in the
past they wrote out what he had said and
then used these to inform their own
decisions and the episode then ended
with them handing over the script to the
doctor so that he could go back and
record the scenes for the DVDs in order
to make it so that the events carried
out the exact same way it basically
makes he who remains unbeatable as he
already knows the outcome but he says
it's necessary they learn this in order
to finish things the way that they're
supposed to be free will it seems is all
an illusion and this idea is hammered
home at rensslayer's office by
hiramobius who debate back and forth
between keeping things the same and
changing them for the better the pair
duke it out and rensslayer says that
he's no danger to her possibly because
Miss minutes filled her in on all the
ins and outs of exactly what would
happen she leaves and we don't know
exactly where she's gone to but it is
possible that she's teamed up with Kang
in an alternate universe rensslayer was
of course Kang's love interest in the
comics so that just makes a lot of sense
and potentially she's at the alternate
TVA that we see at the end now go back
to Kang's oh he he remains or whatever
and he says he's been dubbed many names
by many people and this is a nod to all
the monikers that Kang has gone under
there's been Nathaniel Richards ramatut
immortus and of course Kang the
Conqueror which he pays lip service to
when saying what others have called him
he recounts his backstory namely
Nathaniel richards's past in the 31st
Century or is it the future anyway he
talks about all the variants of him that
discovered one another and how they
initially were a positive force but that
there were others that wanted to rule we
learned that they were the ones behind
the multiversal war and thus he remains
has tried to streamline the entire
timeline to avoid this conflict so that
he can still rule but that he remains
and challenged by himself Kang talks
about how eliaith is a being that he
came across and that he became his pet
which is another theory we got right
yeah we got let's start I'll stop
packing myself on the back for getting
everything right and maybe a million
things wrong but this calls back to the
comics as in that Elias initially tried
to destroy one of Kang's Dimensions but
he defeated it and then turned it into
his guard dog using it he wiped out
almost every timeline and seemingly
averted all-out War he hints to his
other variants who we will know that be
meeting one of in Ant-Man quantumania he
knows it's either his way or something
worse and that the dictatorship the TVA
has is best for all the heartbeat in the
Apple also remains on his desk which
might be an orthodox strange namely the
scene in which he learned how to change
time Kang says there are two outcomes
with either him being in control or it
being Selby and Loki neither of these
actually end up true and it does make
you wonder who gave him the script
obviously there's a higher power over
this entire thing and will no doubt be
getting more clues towards that in
season 2. now he says he's lived a
million lifetimes and this is the only
one that works which might be a nod to
the one timeline amongst the 14 million
that doctor strange mentioned in
Infinity War it's a very Willy
wonka-esque moment in which he reveals
that he's waited Millennia for someone
to take his role and that he now has two
people I have to say it's a really
incredible portrayal and mages is
clearly chewing up the scenery and
stealing the scenes every time that he's
on camera it's an amazing debut and it
leaves you questioning what you would do
in this situation they reach a point
where Kang doesn't know what's going to
happen and this is demonstrated by him
dropping something without knowing that
it would fall we watch as the time
stream splits off into its own thing and
the choice is left up to Loki and Sylvie
Kang takes off his time twister and he
actually appreciates the unknown Sylvie
goes to kill him but Loki stays her hand
and the pair go head-to-head with them
arguing over the opposing views of
democracy versus fascism that's probably
a bit welcome me to say but Loki wants a
dictatorship to stop even worse things
from happening whereas Selby would
rather the choice was left up to the
individuals obviously we know from a
meta point of view exactly who's coming
down the line but Loki very much wants
to use her and himself to keep order
whereas Sylvie is happy to see it
descend into chaos I love that the Pergo
head to head and considering the fight
choreography has been lacking slightly
in the earlier episodes they really
knock it out of the park here lucky
confesses his love for himself and it
seems like he's won Sylvia around but
she betrays him and sends him back to
the TVA so that she can kill Kang he
says I'll see you soon and gives her a
wink because he now knows that the
variant versions of him will rise up and
come to destroy all this very much could
be setting up Secret Wars in the MCU
which though featured Dr Doom is Lily
villain may have Kang at the center that
had a multiversal war in which timelines
in variants battle for dominance and I'm
glad that we're going to be finally
hearing about variants that aren't
covered related now I realize when
re-watching last week's episode that we
actually had a clue Sylvie would do this
when talking about her Loki said she was
different because she didn't want to
take over the TVA she wanted to take it
down thus Loki knew it was in his nature
to make this choice and try to rule
whereas she would always be the one who
wanted to destroy it it completely
fractures and destroys the entire
timeline and no doubt we will be getting
several versions of the character
popping up in the MCU with Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness and
know a home likely being the films that
Focus heavily on this we end with all
our attention on Loki who finds Mobius
in Hunter B15 and he tells them that the
timeline has been freed and that several
bad variants are coming Mobius has no
idea who he is and we realize that he's
now in an alternate version of the TVA
in which Kang is the ruler it's a
chilling way to end the season and we
know that this version is likely
preparing those inside the TVA for
all-out war on the other versions of the
timeline the statue we see has the exact
same uniform as Kang the Conqueror and
whereas he who remains was more in line
with a mortise we now know that this is
the villain who's going to be ruling it
all now we do know that our Mobius and
Hunter B15 are looking for Loki so once
the timeline fractures I think they'll
be able to jump about from University
Universe they'll then track him down and
potentially Sylvie will realize her
mistake when it all starts to crumble I
can see Loki actually fixing the
timeline himself and taking over the TBA
and then streamlining it into one
timeline whilst the MCU all goes to hell
in the other films and shows it's a
great way to end the season and in the
post-credits scene we get to confirm
that we are getting season 2. now we'll
talk about this in just a bit but
firstly I want to go over where I'd rank
this series amongst the rest I
re-watched Falcon and the Winter Soldier
alongside One Division and I would
probably rank this above the both of
them even though I wasn't all that
enamored by the third episode one
division is probably in second place for
me and that's probably because I grew up
watching a lot of the shows and sitcoms
that it was parodying and I felt the
production values on not only the set
but even down to the theme Tunes were
all bang on I just appreciated all the
work that went into it and also the core
message of grief it really really worked
for me and uh were you watching it I did
enjoy it without nitpicking every
sentence and trying to find Clues as to
why Mephisto was behind it all which yes
I was wrong again now Falcon was a lot
more of a straightforward story on the
surface but it dealt with themes like
race as well as Legacy I think that it's
also an incredible sort of coming of age
story I don't know if coming of age is
the right phrase but basically Sam
accepting that he has to become Captain
America whilst Bucky accepts his past
and acknowledges what he must do to make
things right let me know below what I
should have said there as I'm sorry it's
very very early now I'd still like to
place Loki above all that and I think
it's been an amazing journey of
self-discovery that has not only
explored the ideas of the Multiverse but
it's also present them in a really fun
way whilst showing someone so full of
hate learning to love themselves I had a
lot of fun with it and now we have
season two confirmed I thought I'd talk
about some of the things that we already
know about it Nate Moore a producer at
Marvel recently told Indie Wyatt that
Loki was dreamed up with the idea that
it would lend itself to multiple Seasons
Clark Greg who you will probably know as
Agent Coulson Also let's slip back and
make a variety that Hiddleston is
working on four more episodes than were
present in this entry when talking with
them he said I'd be lying if I didn't
say boy that would really be interesting
to start the experiment over doing 10
episodes or 12 episodes the way Tom
Hiddleston told me he was doing on Loki
with that kind of budget and that Marvel
Cinematic production team now whether
this is him just getting the episode
about wrong or letting us know that the
next season might make up the other 6 to
12 or that they could be 10 to 12
episodes we don't know but there is
further mounting evidence will be seeing
the god of Mischief sooner rather than
later according to brother production
weekly season 2 will reportedly start
filming in January 2022 and due to the
speed that Disney are putting these
together and then releasing them it is
possible that we might even see the next
one at the end of next year in addition
to this there's also been several hints
and articles that Mobius and some of the
other versions of Loki could be
appearing in future projects there's so
many different aspects they could
explore and say Hiddleston does want to
hang up the horns we still have a
version of the god of Mischief that
could be popping up at some point down
the line so lots to look forward to and
on the 11th of August we will be
starting our weekly what if coverage I
was gonna do a trailer breakdown but I'm
sure if you've been watching my most
recent videos you'll know I've been
pretty bunged up with man flu so I
thought I'd just take a rest over the
weekend and get back to normal for this
one however we have got a lot of
interesting aspects such as killmonger
saving Tony Stark Thor vs Ultron Captain
Carter what if t'challa was picked up by
yondu which will sadly be the last
performance by the actor and there's
also so what if Loki wouldn't Thor
Marvel zombies and a lot more to sink
your teeth into hey so that's our Loki
video and I just want to give a huge
thank you for choosing us today I know
there's so many amazing channels out
there doing breakdowns such as new rock
stars screen Crush Canadian lad Beyond
epic real rejects 3C film superhero
Nexus austinberg Zack Pope Cosmic Wonder
movie files everything always emergency
awesome and a lot more that I'll
definitely be kicking myself for
forgetting so shout out to them and
shout out to yourself for coming back to
support this channel you're the best and
it means the world to me to see you
every week even if you disliked it which
I know it was you but I still appreciate
the view now as a thank you we are
running a competition at the end of the
month the giveaway three copies of an
MCU box set of the Winner's Choice all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the finale we pick the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last just want to on
screen right now say that to you then
message me on Twitter at heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the Easter eggs in Black Widow which
will be linked on screen right now we've
gone over the full movie and uncovered
some of the best deals in it so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want something else after this without
the way thank you for singing through
the video I've been poor and I'll see
you next time take care